about 200 years ago Napoleon famously
warned
he said that China sleep for when she
wakes
she will check the world despite this
early warning the West chose to go to
sleep at precisely the moment when China
and India and the rest of Asia woke up
why did this happen I'm here to address
this great mystery now what do I mean
when I say the West chose to go to sleep
here I'm referring to the failure of the
West to react intelligently and
thoughtfully the new wall environment
that's obviously been created by the
return of Asia as a friend of the West's
I feel anguish by this so my goal today
is to try to help the West but I have to
begin the story first by talking about
how the West actually woke up the rest
of the world look at chart 1 from the
year 1 to the year 1820 the two largest
economies of the world were always those
of China and India so it's only in the
last 200 years that Europe took off
followed by North America so the past
200 years of world history have
therefore been a major historical
aberration all aberrations come to a
natural end and this is what we are
seeing and if you look at chart 2 you'll
see how quickly and how forcefully China
and India are coming back the big
who woke up China and India the only
honest answer to this question is that
it was Western civilization that did so
we all know that the West was the first
to successfully modernize transform
itself initially he used his power to
colonize and dominate the world but over
time it shat the gifts of Western wisdom
with the rest of the world let me add
here that I have personally benefited
from this sharing of Western wisdom when
I was born in Singapore which was then a
poor British colony in 1948 I
experienced like three-quarters of
humanity then extreme poverty indeed on
the first day when I went to school at
the age of six I was put in a special
feeding program because I was
technically undernourished now as you
can see I'm over nourished but the
greatest gift I got was that our Western
education now since I personally
traveled this journey from third-world
poverty to a comfortable middle-class
existence I can speak with great
conviction about the impact of Western
wisdom and the sharing of Western wisdom
with the world and one in particular
gift that the West share was the art of
reasoning now reasoning was not invented
by the West its inherent in all cultures
and civilizations amateur Sen has
described how deeply embedded it is in
Indian civilization yet there's also no
doubt that he was the West that carried
the art of reasoning to a much higher
level and through the Scientific
Revolution the Enlightenment the
Industrial Revolution the West really
raised it forcefully and equally
importantly use this apply
to solve many major practical problems
and the Western shared this are of a
flight reasoning with the rest of the
world and I can tell you that it led to
what I call three silent revolutions and
as an Asian I can I can say describe how
the silent revolutions transform Asia
the first revolution was in economics
the main reason why so many Asian
economies including the communist
societies of China and Vietnam have
performed so spectacularly well in
economic development is because they
finally understood absorb and i
implementing free-market economics a
gift from the West Adam Smith was right
if you let markets decide productivity
goes up the second gift was
psychological here too I can speak from
personal experience when I was young my
mother and her generation believed that
life was determined by fate you couldn't
do anything about it my generation and
the generation of Asians after me
believe that we can take charge and we
can improve our lives and this may
explain for example the spike of
entrepreneurship you see all throughout
Asia today and if you travel through
Asia today you will also see the results
of the third revolution the revolution
of good governance now as a result of
good governance travel in Asia you see
better health care better education that
are infrastructure there are public
policies it's a different world now
having transformed
the world through the sharing of Western
wisdom with the rest of the world the
logical and rational response of the
West should have been say hey we have to
adjust and adapt to this new world
instead the West chose to go to sleep
why did it happen I believe that
happened
because the West became distracted with
two major events the first event was the
end of the Cold War yes the end of the
Cold War was a great victory the West
defeated the mighty Soviet Union without
firing a shot
amazing but you know when you have a
great victory like this it also leads to
arrogance and hubris and this hubris was
best captured in a very famous essay by
Francis Fukuyama called the end of
history
now Fukuyama was putting across a very
sophisticated message but all that the
West heard from his essay was that we
the liberal democracies we have
succeeded we don't have to change we
don't have to adapt it's only the rest
of the world that has to change and
adapt unfortunately like a dangerous
opiate this essay did a lot of brain
damage to the West because he put them
to sleep just at precisely the moment
when China and India were waking up and
the rest didn't adjust and adapt the
second major event was 9/11 which
happened in 2001 and as we know 9/11
caused a lot of shock and grief I
personally experienced the shock and
grief because I was in Manhattan
when 9/11 happened 9/11 also generated a
lot of anger and in this anger the
United States decided to invade
Afghanistan and later Iraq and
unfortunately partly as a result of this
anger the West didn't notice the
significance of another event that
happened also in 2001 China joined the
World Trade Organization
now when you suddenly inject 900 million
new workers into the global capitalist
system you would naturally lead to what
the Economist Joseph Schumpeter called
creative destruction Western workers
lost their jobs they saw their incomes
stagnate clearly people had to think
about new competitive policies workers
needed retraining workers needed new
skills none of this was done so partly
as a result of this the United States of
America became the only major developed
society where the average income of the
bottom 50% yes 50% average income went
down over a 30-year period from 1980 to
2010 so partly as a result of this it
led eventually to the election of Donald
Trump in 2016 who exploited the anger
the working classes who are
predominantly white it also contributed
to the rise of populism in Europe and
one wonders could this populism have
been avoided if the West had not been
distracted by the end of the
all war and by 911 but a big question we
face today is this is it too late has
the West lost everything and my answer
is that it's not too late
it is possible for the West to recover
and come back in strength and using the
Western art of reasoning I would
recommend that the West adopt a new 3m
strategy minimalists multilateral and
Machiavellian why minimalist
now even though Western domination has
ended the West continues to intervene
and interfere in the affairs of many
other societies this is unwise
this is generating anger and resentment
especially in Islamic societies it's
also draining the resources and spirits
of Western societies now I know that the
Islamic world is having difficulties
modernizing it will have to find its way
by it's more likely to do so if it is
left alone to do so now I can say this
with some conviction because I come from
a region Southeast Asia which has almost
as many Muslims as the Arab world 266
million Muslims Southeast Asia is also
the one of the most diverse corners of
planet Earth because you also have
hundred and forty-six million Christians
149 million Buddhists Mahayana Buddhists
and hilly on a buddhist and you also
have millions of towers and Confucianism
and Hindus and even communists and once
known as the Balkans of Asia Southeast
Asia today should be experiencing a
clash of civilizations instead what you
see in Southeast Asia is one of the most
peaceful and prosperous corners of
planet Earth with the second most
successful regional multilateral
organization asiye
so clearly minimalism can work the West
should try it out but but I'm also aware
that minimalism cannot solve all the
problems there are some hard problems
that really have to be dealt with al
Qaeda Isis there remain dangerous
threats they must be found they must be
destroyed the question is is it wise for
the West which represents 12 percent of
the world's population yes 12% to fight
these threats on its own or to fight
with the remaining 88% of the world's
population and the logical and rational
answer is that you should work with the
remaining 88% now whereas one goal if
you want to get the support of humanity
there's only one place the United
Nations now I've been ambassador to the
UN twice maybe that makes me a bit
biased but I can tell you that working
with the UN can lead to success why is
it that the first Iraq war fought by
President George HW Bush succeed well
the second Iraq war fought by his son
president george w bush failed one key
reason is that the senior Bush went to
the UN to get the support of the global
community before fighting the war in
Iraq so multilateralism works that's
another reason why we have to work with
the UN the world is shrinking we are
becoming a small interdependent global
village or villages need village
councils and the only global village
council we have as the lead UN secretion
role Kofi Annan said is the UN now as a
geopolitical analyst I do know that is
often considered naive to work with a UN
so now let me inject my Machiavellian
point now Machiavelli is a figure
who's often derided in the West but the
liberal philosopher Isaiah Berlin
reminded us that the goal of Machiavelli
was to promote virtue not evil so what
is the Machiavellian point it's this
what is the best way for the West to
constrain the new rising powers that are
emerging and the answer is that the best
way to constrain them is through
multilateral rules and multilateral
norms multilateral institutions and
multilateral processes now let me
conclude with one final big message as a
longtime friend of the West I am acutely
aware of how pessimistic Western
societies have become many in the West
don't believe that a great future lies
ahead for them that their children will
not have a better lives so please do not
fear the future or the rest of the world
now I can say this with some conviction
because as a Hindu Cindy I actually feel
a direct cultural connection with
societies diverse cultures and societies
all the way from Tehran to Tokyo and
more than half of humanity lives in this
space
so with this direct cultural connection
I can say with great conviction that if
the West chooses to adopt a wiser
strategy of being minimalist
multilateral and Machiavellian the rest
of the world will be happy to work with
the West so a great future lies ahead
for Humanity let's embrace it together
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]